[Musique]
quel est le temps de se retourner
elle sent la mort de son père se permet
sur moi ne discute pas ma fille mon père
je ne comprends pas la grand mère m'a
tout raconté averti chézy saisi la jeune
femme
ses jambes cette son poids elle sent une
deuxième main non plus tendre celle de
son frère et nous saisissons montrera
elle relève le village vers son père
ouvre la bouche pour parler mais n'y
parvient pas son père la regarde avec
calme et se came la technique plus c'est
la violence dont il a toujours visé à
son égard ne peut pas attaquer au maire
elle ne pouvait pas garder le souffle
pour le bal des femmes de wisteria lane
on peut passer par le professionnel en
lycée professionnel par les loisirs
et puis on peut les insulter en
puissance si vous faites le renaudot
vous rencontrerez l'auteur laisse nous
c'est une grosse carotte pour rencontrer
un auteur qu est enfin un auteur kaka
qui est vivant certains élèves du
renaudot vont venir lire au cdi le temps
du renaudot et après disparaîtront et
d'autres vont continuer à venir à
fréquenter ça dépend vraiment des élèves
j'adore y participer romain dos parce
que j'avais la jambe dans le plâtre est
étonnamment étonnamment je suis
pessimiste est une bonne occasion de
passer le temps peut-être les médias
parce que c'était pas trop mon kif et
début j'ai préféré par les routes par
les rouges nous en sommes qu loup n'a
qu'à la moitié de notre terme est passé
la moitié de notre existence est là en
arrière déroulé un content qu'ils nous
sommes qui nous avons été jusqu'à
présent ce que nous avons été capables
de risquer ou non ce qui nous a peiné ce
qui nous arrive
nous pouvons encore nous jurer que la
mue n'est pas achevée que demain nous
serons un autre que celui ou celle que
nous sommes vraiment reste à venir c'est
de plus en plus difficile à croire
et même si cela advenait l'espérance de
vie de ce nouvel être va s'amenuiser
chaque jour cependant que croit l'âge de
l'ancien celui qui nous auront de toute
façon été pendant des années
quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il arrive
maintenant ça raconte un petit peu
l'existence de l'être humain qui on va
être son affaire de notre vie
étaient des choses des questions que je
me pose vachement je peux encore à du
tout ça je sais pas trop ce que j'ai
fait de ma vie j'ai une idée mais je
suis pas trop encore et hunt livre sa
part d'un auto stoppeur qui voyagent et
qui rencontraient des gens c'est quelque
chose que j'aimerais beaucoup faire plus
tard voyage et peut être même faire de
l'auto stop je sais pas encore j'aime
beaucoup rencontrer des gens leur parler
vive enfin vivre tout simplement et être
heureux aussi
j'ai eu beaucoup de mangas est également
gentillesse à peu à la philosophie sur
réellement sur la liberté l'être humain
tout ça semi-finis et bastille place à
part un petit peu de savon c'est pour ça
que j'ai accroché potes et je trouvais
ça intéressant de partager je pensais
qu'on se livre pour la servir pour ne
pas qu ils recrutent pas me dit qu'il
m'aime